if there's one lesson to be taken from
Dragonball Z it's that when you feel
like you've given it your all just
trying digging deeper sure it's not
really practical unless you're a super
humanly powerful alien but inspiring
nonetheless time after time when all
hope seems lost Goku and the Z Warriors
miraculously tap into a previously
undiscovered wellspring of power to
defeat a seemingly insurmountable
villain and when they're not fighting
they're usually engaged in impossibly
difficult training regimes who could
forget the hyperbolic time chamber
unless you want to die you have to get
stronger Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot translates the Z warriors
constant pursuit of self-improvement
into a variety of complementary systems
that are almost as deep as Goku
seemingly bottomless ocean of strength
as an action-rpg
the primary means of growth is of course
XP get into fights and complete sub
stories to earn XP and you'll gradually
level up to boost your core stats simple
where it gets more complex is when you
get into cooking amassing Z orbs and
organizing your soul emblems cooking as
we touched on it in our first video is
made possible by foraging and hunting
for ingredients around the world by
chatting to NPCs and completing certain
sub quests you'll build up a repertoire
of recipes that can be prepared at
campfires located all over the map
however to get the best dishes with the
best buffs you'll need to talk to cooks
and no cook is more important to Goku
than his wife chichi
head home every once in a while and
she'll cook up for meals that will
provide significant temporary buffs but
will also provide permanent boosts to
your base stats while exploring the
world you'll also happen upon thousands
of Z orbs think of these as a skill
currency differently colored orbs help
to open up and enhance super attacks on
your characters skill tree they're
typically color-coded based on the area
in which you discover them for example
verdant areas like forests are more
likely to house green Z orbs while
diving under water will net you plenty
of blue ones certain super attacks
feature a green icon which means that
you need to seek out additional D medals
and spend them at specified training
grounds D medals are hidden throughout
the game's massive map and a fairly
tricky to spot normally fortunately they
emanate a tell-tale aura that's only
visible when you activate your key
search which makes them less
needle-in-a-haystack and more needle
with an aura in a haystack
finally and the most innovative of
Kakarot character growth systems is the
community board as you progress through
the stories and sub stories you'll earn
soul emblems for the numerous characters
you meet assist and in some cases defeat
there are seven themed community boards
each offering different perks for
example the Z warriors community is
geared towards enhancing your prowess in
combat while the cooking community
enhances the efficacy of meals to grow
each community you'll have to place
suitable soil emblems on the board so in
the case of the Z warriors community
you'll want to be adding the likes of go
hand piccolo and krillen soul emblems
furthermore placing certain soul emblems
together triggers additional link
bonuses that will make it easier to
boost that community's rank so if you've
got even a passing knowledge of
relationships in the show you'll
definitely have an advantage you really
have grown up haven't you you look just
like Goku and he was again you can help
Goku achieve his true potential right
now because Dragon Ball Z Kakarot is
available to play on PC Xbox one and
PlayStation 4